YOU ARE SO DEAD.
- BRING IT.
- YOU ARE SO DEAD, DUDE.
- OKAY, HOLD THE PHONE.
YOU ARE FULLY TORQUED, BRO.
- WELL, YEAH, I WAS ABOUT
TO BONE THAT LADY!
- OHH.
- YEAH, OKAY, YES.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO UNTORQUE YOUR BONE
BEFORE WE CAN
CONTINUE ANYTHING.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
IT'S AN UNWRITTEN RULE:
WARRIORS CANNOT COLLIDE
WHILE ERECT.
- FINE.
- TAKE FIVE.
- CRANK DOWN.
- CRANK IT DOWN.
- I MEAN,
IT'S A GREAT BACKYARD.
- YEAN, IT'S PRETTY NICE.
THINKING ABOUT PUTTING
A KOI POND OVER THERE.
- YOU GOT THE ROOM FOR IT.
- WATERFALL.
- MIGHT AS WELL.
- YEAH.
- AND THE BONER'S DOWN!
FIGHT!
- OHH! COME ON!
YEAH, BABY!
YEAH, BABY, WHAT?
- WHOA!
- OH, YEAH.
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
- CHOKE IT.
- BREAK IT UP!
BREAK IT UP! BREAK IT UP!
- WHAT?
- YOU GUYS BOTH
HAVE BONERS NOW.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
both: WOW!
- IT'S CONTAGIOUS, DUDE!
YOU'RE TOO FLESHY.
PUT ON A SHIRT.
- THIS GUYS SMELLS GREAT.
IT'S LIKE A COCONUT OIL.
WHAT IS THAT?
- THANK YOU.
IT'S MY TANNING CREAM.
- OH! BONERS ARE DOWN.
- I'M GONNA RUIN YOU, MAN.
- I'M GONNA STRAIGHT DO
WHAT I CAME HERE TO DO.
- I'M GONNA STRAIGHT WRECK YOU!
- YOU'RE GONNA DIE AT MY FEET,
YOU SMALL-MINDED--
- OKAY, I'VE GOT A BONER.
- I'VE GOT ONE TOO.
SOON AS I SAID "MY FEET,"
IT WAS LIKE...
- YEAH, ALL THE BLOOD
JUST SORT OF--
THAT HAPPENED TO ME TOO.
THAT'S WHAT'S WEIRD ABOUT IT.
- THAT'S COOL.
- THIS IS REALLY WEIRD.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'RE NOT GONNA FIGHT RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S OFFICIAL.
I'M TORQUED.
YOU'RE TORQUED RIGHT NOW.
BUT I KNOW YOU CAN LEAVE.
YOU CAN LEAVE MY HOUSE
AND RESPECT MY WOMAN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN DO.
- FINE.
- LEAVE.
- GLADLY.
- WELL, I HAVE
A LITTLE ANNOUNCEMENT
FOR YOU, SIR, BECAUSE
YOU BROKE THE BLOOD OATH,
AND I WANT YOU TO LEAVE
OUR WIZARD CREW.
- WHAT? YEAH.
LIKE I CARE.
- AND I'M TAKING
THE BEATS BACK.
- AH, DON'T TAKE THE BEATS.
- YEAH.
- NO, DON'T TAKE THE BEATS.
OHH! DON'T TAKE THE BEATS!
I'M SUPER-SAD
ABOUT THE BEATS!
I DON'T CARE, DUDE, BECAUSE I
HAVE A BODYBUILDING COMPETITION
ON THE SAME DAY.
AND THAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT TO ME
THAN DRESSING UP
LIKE A FAIRY WIZARD.
- WOW.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, MAN?
IT DID NOT HAVE
TO GO LIKE THIS.
WE'RE OUT OF HERE.
- YOU'RE SUCH A DUMB IDIOT!
- WOW, OKAY.
I DON'T CARE.
I HOPE THIS GOES AWAY SOON.
YOU INFECTED ME
WITH YOUR BONER.